throw your sister off the ferry and hide
in the washroom while your husband holds
your co-workers hostage because we have
another episode of the changeling where
everything is going off the rails
forgot about that in this video we'll be
taking a deep dive into episode 6 and
answering all the episodes important
questions keep in mind I have not read
the book so any theories here are based
solely off what we've seen so far I've
left timestamps below so you can see the
topics we'll be covering now let's get
into it up until this point most of the
changeling has focused on Apollo kagwa
and the search for his murderous wife
Emma episode 6 gives us a glimpse at
what exactly Emma was up to after she
killed her quote unquote baby remember
that the events of this episode take
place roughly three months prior to
Apollo making his way to the island in
episode 4. that's because he spent three
months in jail for holding up Emma's
Library an event Emma actually witnessed
herself when she was hiding in the
washroom the first shot of the episode
is Emma holding a tea kettle we saw her
heating this up in episode 3 and picking
it off the stove feeling no pain her
seemingly superhero-like Powers aside
what purpose did this Kettle serve was
it to burn Brian we actually don't know
how Brian died the only person to see
Brian's dead body was the building
superintendent who in episode 3 tells
Apollo he never saw anything like it but
the news report this episode states that
Brian's body was found quote
unresponsive could the kettle be part of
some sort of ritual remember that cow
asks Emma what did you see after you did
what we asked of you almost as if there
was a particular Way Emma had to go
about killing her child Emma's Escape
wouldn't be possible without the help of
her sister Kim in episode 2 she follows
her sister as she acquires the chains
that will tie up Apollo provided to her
by one of Cal's followers she has no
knowledge about what her sister is about
to do but now it seems like she knows a
whole lot more she helps her sister
Escape says she has to do this alone and
pushes her her in the water there's no
way any rational person would Aid their
mentally unstable sister in committing
the murders of their son and husband
unless Kim knows something we don't she
seems to be working with Cal reminding
Emma what Cal said that this has to be
done alone and alerts the rowboat that
she's on her way it seems like a big
question for both Emma and Kim is if
Emma's really mentally ill like her
mother or under some sort of spell and
hopefully she will find some answers on
this island Emma looks as though she's
in some sort of Trance when we see her
at the beginning of the episode perhaps
she's seeing something remember that Cal
asks her as soon as she gets on the
island what she saw after she did what
she asked of her left in the crib is a
tree branch and she has no idea how it
got there part of Emma's Journey this
episode is understanding the
significance of this Branch she asks
another mother if there was anything
left behind when she killed her child
this woman says a leaf this Leaf belongs
to a Norwegian maple a particularly
invasive species whose aggressive Roots
the narrator says girdle even the parent
tree choking itself to death it seems
the Norwegian maple is a metaphor for
William the Norwegian who is
metaphorically choking Apollo and Emma
by taking hold of their child so Emma
embarks on a journey to investigate
every Norwegian maple in New York but
it's Wheels who suggest she starts in
Little Norway immigrants there first
arrived in 1825 which is the same year
that persecuted Norwegians from episode
1 left their Homeland with all this
emphasis on forests like those mentioned
in Apollo's book to the waters and the
wild it makes sense to start there
because there's an actual Force there
but many questions still remain why
would the people who took baby Brian
leave behind such a clue is there any
significance to this Branch Beyond it
being a clue to leader to Little Norway
much remains to be seen after escaping
her apartment Emma receives a text
message from an unknown number remember
she had been receiving dozens of these
messages in the months leading up to
Brian's death this time however the text
messages read with William's voice that
we heard him use at the end of episode
5. he says they told you to ditch the
phone but can you really quit me the
only one who knows what really happened
this is pretty cryptic they told you to
ditch the phone likely refers to Cal and
the women but why would he say he's the
only one who knows what really happened
likely because William is the only one
who knows where Brian is William has
this almost Supernatural like quality to
him he got nearly beaten to death a few
episodes ago and now seems totally fine
so when I think of a Norwegian creature
that is connected to the supernatural I
obviously think of a troll as I was
researching I came across this article
which states in folk tales trolls would
come out of the primordial forest and
steal away Christian children replacing
them with their changeling troll babies
this sounds a lot like what's going on
let's be real Emma's been able to do
some pretty superhuman stuff from
holding the burning Kettle to descending
the fire escape like she's some Parkour
expert I can't help but think something
inside inside her is giving her this
power and perhaps this has something to
do with the South American witch but
with those Powers also come some
weaknesses if Emma is indeed some sort
of witch then according to mythology
witches can't swim and this seems to be
the case for Emma this episode when
she's flung off the ferry she almost
drowns until she's rescued and later on
we'll see her chase after the rowboat
and drown again only saving herself by
grabbing onto a nearby rope I also found
this very odd detail which is only
really noticeable with the closed
captioning on after she survives
drowning she meows the words first comes
love the beginning line of a nursery
rhyme which is where commonly burned at
the stake and one of the last lines Kim
says to Emma before throwing her off the
boat is I can't let you burn for this
her mother was also burned to death back
to swimming in episode 4 Apollo tells us
that he can't swim if he happens to be
the son of a witch it's possible that
passed down to him as well it would also
explain how he's able to get to this
island he is part which one of the lines
from to the waters in the wild that
we've seen over and over again is the
one Emma carves into her jail cell they
bathe The Dusk they hide it with guile
at home in the forest forever lost in
the wild this is the passage Apollo will
find months later my first guess is that
this refers to a changeling something
that is hidden with guile to make it
look like something else it could also
refer to a child for the trolls and
fairies would need to hide the child
they swapped in order to keep them in
their quote-unquote Forest as Emma
leaves the island telling Cal that
she'll never see her again she begins to
glow blue to me this is a manifestation
of her witch power her final line is
Mama's coming for you she is determined
powerful and this lines up with Emma's
friend's depiction of her in that
Norwegian photo as being a sorceress and
it's not uncommon for witches to Glow or
emit light in folklore so this is
currently my best to guess I found it
very interesting that even though none
of the women know where their children
are none of them seem hell-bent on
finding them like Emma is I think Cal
describes them as being tired it's like
they've all given up rather than banding
together to solve this mystery Cal reads
a passage from Alice in Wonderland
that's all about Alice changing there
are also several quotes we've seen
throughout the series found in the
underground like when you believe in
things you don't understand then you
suffer which was found in the subway in
episode 1 after baby Brian's birth
that's it for this episode please make
sure to like And subscribe and for more
bad takes you can follow me on Twitter
and Instagram at thinkstoryyt until next
time remember Daddy loves you very much
foreign